hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play lost the lies okay I am back
here where I just put the lever and I
threw this chair I didn't bring the
other chair with me when I came back but
anyway I'm back here and I know that oh
there's that chair
I know that that's where I went in
before so I'm gonna explore the other
areas before I go there I'm pretty sure
I'm pretty sure that I was missing a key
that I was supposed to grab from in here
I shut up light there's another another
lock door okay whoa caving in I'm so
scary
whew goofy yeah whew whoa Wow as weird
it's actually quite interesting probably
if I touch it it would be bad okay this
is like some sort of generator again
very interesting I've never seen
anything like that before
let's just be a unique implementation or
something rather ah here's another side
what's up here hello anybody rock your
body hello this is a big room us
something rather ah interesting
wow that's a big door do there's
something busted out er
well probably something busted out oh
another staircase I didn't see the first
one no doubt it lick lick lick lick lick
lick lick fade or faded raid now I don't
see anything new let's just close up
somewhere stacks up for some reason I
don't know maybe to cover some other
can't move them alright let's see what's
behind the big broken doors ah a lever
chickadee to get there we go
dammit their generator seems broken some
parts of me see I have to find all parts
to make it work to make it work again
click click click okay
all right so need to find some parts so
that's the overarching objective I need
to do other stuff to get to that point
oh no Billy Mays damn you damn you all
right guess I was just waiting for me to
come back here yeah what was that was
that I saw something too clickable
disappeared that's weird
I don't know no no no big big panel
maybe I could throw something at that
gets to open up okay it doesn't look
like there's anything else here mmm
damn it I might have to go whoa Kurt
come on Kurt chunk her chunk Wow
what the hell is freaky that was moving
ed movin okay
so that giant panel came off that's
weird
and that's not a ladder I think is it
nope okay
ladder no all right I guess there's
nothing else here let me just try to
throw a rock at the come on give me a
throwable rock there we are
oh come on don't be like that I'll be
like that damn you damn you all are you
come on please please please please no
all right find your own douches you're
all douches you're all douches I love
you rocks are douches okay let me go
back down the other way actually no let
me go back down this way because there's
the other side the other side that I
want to go through I'll go through here
boopadoo boop-boo-boo-boop okay now if
it's the same deal then I know that
there's definitely something that I need
to find so oh it's not the same deal
whoa that's a lot of blood a lot of BL
double O to be blood
all right how roll oil who's here and
yet bloody
gyal Witcher lots of blood comes to this
point because there's a trapdoor haha so
smart come Richard you're useful for
something
haha now for some reason I'm always
compelled to break those things that the
only thing in here go down the trap door
aha
maybe there was a trapdoor the other one
too this one was just really obvious
come on now don't be like that the
number of mechanics damn you get it I'm
down yeah I'm down this seems smart
oh damn you Billy Mays mother fire
somehow there's got to be a way to go
down there oh just I heard of it my face
is now covered in Jam okay no kind of
oil barely conscious
alright what's the monster comin at me I
don't need to take like who it's one of
these things we found the power source
it's in the temple but things gone
terribly wrong many people died some
information should still be in the
temple okay okey
see nothing nothing that's the Fano
statute it's key it was a key aha thank
you you are useful ma'am
damn come on break it BAM oh it's
already broken isn't it not it is let's
see damn it alright come on what's going
on here fine that was it I got the key
to the tomb door wait is that the tomb
door that's not the door all right bring
it on hello
can I please that's where the that's
where the oil pot was a good box box box
chair chair chair chair I have use for
you you're the only chair you'll do Big
Bertha
here we go
Ariel come on get in there get in there
there we go got it wait no this isn't it
oh yes it is
never mind hell's wrong well yeah loop
right up that chair ladder ladder chair
so I got chairs on my mind Big Bertha
was there thunderous thighs
Aaron is a tall Billy Mays yeah yeah
yeah blah blah Blau that was scary
give me that that all right put the
dread body there's a lot of blood that
noise it's like steam blowing in my ear
transportation go this way
I mean there was other stuff that needed
exploring maybe this is the way out if
it is I don't want to add I want to go
back just in case I want to look maybe
there's some specialty but I don't know
no
like there are certain ways it wants me
to go first and then not okay this is
the way out how you get out so let's go
back down and then I'll go through the
way I'll get whatever because I don't
want to miss out on essential story
items or things that are important or
maybe it's just nothing maybe there's
nothing there at all and I'm just
wasting time
either way gotta find out no way to know
except to know yourself know right
good come at me Billy Mays yeah didn't
think so
I'm Way too brave to be scared by the
likes of that that screeching is
annoying okay now going away climb down
on Big Bertha thank you baby
aah there was nothing I'm an idiot I'm a
big fat idiot I'm the biggest city in
the world
I'm such an idiot I'm an idiot I wasted
so much time
oh man Wulfric friend now I have to tell
a story just to keep you guys
entertained for my idiocy
what should I can tell what story should
I tell how about this story if I'm such
a giant a-hole ah ah yes son of a [ __ ]
why did you do that to me why didn't you
do that just get in the hole please nope
don't do that again I swear it's not
laying me in the hole God Lee make up
your own joke there
I swear what's going on here let me in
let me in please
can I get in Rudy please pretty please
good night what the hell is going on
what the hell is happening here that's
like I'm not crouching I'm not able to
crouch and there we go finally gah it's
like it impossible to fit in the story
of my life oh shut up Billy Mays
I know my face is all covered in Jam
again
all right come on come on who's out
there who wants some hey anybody didn't
think so
oh not again not again come on come on
there we go I don't remember this there
all right fine Oh me I need your stupid
door anyway
oh come really
what is key to anything something under
the boxes oh oh oh how can I not
what can I purchase that with a box but
not do anything else oh did you see s
summer song on Udo badass well what the
[ __ ] okay this is weird
Wow
you ate the box it ate it's eating the
boxes really it just goes right through
can I go right through I can all [ __ ] I
broke the game ah I broke the game I
broke it I broke
I broke the game by bi-level bye-bye
I'm hoping that it'll die from a fall
there we go
death oh that was weird
it was just eating the boxes I assumed
that there was some way I don't know I
don't know found a bug all right make
your other get no way I'm all the way
back here but I Mikey maybe I was
supposed to die that way it was like a
just some big cosmic joke for this guy
don't you see if this is the tomb nope
okay well then follow me whatever
whatever yes I get out now
thank you
I'm thinking that maybe that was what
how he was supposed to be I mean that
was like a really obvious place to just
fall through so maybe no hot dark it's
so dark I'm so scared of the dark okay
that was the room with the spinning
machine I'm guessing the tomb has to be
in the area where I first went in here
and the key the key goes to a door in
there
now this was yeah this just stairs up so
let me go in here back where I was and
maybe I'll find something ahead I get to
see Billy Mays again hey Billy
got a pot for you Billy pop Billy
pot-bellied go darkus hey broken
hahahahaha okay oh come on
what oh come on
this is insanity which Arling the other
doors
was there a center door in the other
room there was wasn't there oh no now
I'm trapped aren't I
oh no I'm trapped ah I am I am totally
trapped Boulder - okay I'm out of time
anyway I'll figure this out in the next
episode guys sorry it's taking so long
so thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next part
bye-bye